NORTH KOREA IS PREPARING TO
CELEBRATE THE MAJOR
ANNIVERSARY.
FRIDAY MARKS 110 YEARS OF ITS
FOUNDING FATHERS BIRTH.
THE FESTIVITIES FOR THE
SO-CALLED DAY OF THE SUN
INVOLVED WEAPONS.
CNN'S PAULA HANCOCK IS COVERING
THIS LIVE FROM SEOUL.
PAUL, BUT ARE WE EXPECTING FROM
THIS, ARTICLE IN THE CONTEXT OF
RUSSIA'S RECENT MISSILE LAUNCH?
>> KIM, WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING IN THE DAYS RUNNING UP
TO THE CELEBRATION, WHICH IS ON
FRIDAY, OUR FESTIVITIES LIKE
EXHIBITIONS, DANCING, WE HAVE
ALSO SEEN KIM JONG-UN, THE
CREATOR, OPENING UP HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN HIS NAME.
AS YOU SAY, THE WEAPONS IS WHAT
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMITTEE'S
GONNA BE LOOKING FOR.
WE KNOW THE USS ABRAHAM LINCOLN,
THE AIRCRAFT CARRIER IS
INCREASING WATERS FOR THIS WEEK,
A POTENTIAL SHOW OF FORCE
AGAINST NORTH KOREA, AND CASES
DECIDE TO TEST ANYTHING.
BUT NORTH KOREA HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO DO.
>> KIM JONG-UN, KNOWS EXACTLY
WHICH MISSILES AND WEAPONS
SYSTEMS HE WANTS TO PERFECT.
SO DO WE, BECAUSE HE TOLD US.
AND GENERALLY LAST YEAR, HE
GAVE ONE OF THE MOST DETAILED
MILITARY REPORTS IN NORTH KOREA
HISTORY, ACCORDING TO STATE RUN
MEDIA.
HIS FIVE-YEAR WISH LIST.
SINCE THEN, HE HAS BEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY WORKING THROUGH
IT.
>> THE NORTH KOREANS REALLY
LAID OUT AN AMBITIOUS AGENDA
FOR MILITARY MODERNIZATION.
IT IS VERY INCREDIBLE.
>> AMONG THEM, A HYPERSONIC
GLIDE VEHICLE, WHICH PERFECTED
CAN EVADE MISSILE EFFECTS
SYSTEMS.
IT IS A BIG IF THE ONLY RUSSIA
AND CHINA HAVE THIS CAPABILITY.
IT MILITARY CONDITIONS
SATELLITE, NECESSARY TO KEEP IT
HIGH ON THE U.S. AND ITS
ALLIES.
ELEMENTS OF IT WERE TESTED THIS
YEAR, BUT THE PENTAGON BELIEVES
IT WAS ITS COVER FOR A SPACE
LAUNCH AND A NEW INTERIM
BALLISTIC MISSILE.
THAT IS 9300 MILES.
IT CAN BE EACH MIDNIGHT UNITED
STATES AND BEYOND.
AND ICBM CAME CLOSER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIALS DOUBT
THE CLAIMS THAT IT WAS THE MOST
RECENTLY UNVEILED.
MISSILE EXPERTS SAY IT HAS THAT
THAT WEAPON MAY HAVE FELT ANY
RECUR THERE.
>> IT IS LIKELY TO BE MULTIPLE
WARHEADS.
ALSO IT WAS FIRED ON A NORMAL
TRAJECTORY, IT CAN HIT ANYWHERE
ON THE CONTINENTAL UNITED
STATES.
>> AND TACKLER NUCLEAR WEAPONS
--
>> CAN JOIN HAS BOOKING QUITE
EXPLICITLY BUT THAT THE COURT
KNEW UP.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS THEY'RE DESIGNED TO
PEOPLE ON SIMILAR TO THE
ROCKETS AND SMALLER SHORT RANGE
BALLISTIC MISSILES.
>> MEANWHILE, NUCLEAR --
IT IS MAYBE SMALLER THAN IS
LAST.
SEPTEMBER 2017, TREMORS FROM
WHICH COULD BE FELT IN
NEIGHBORING CHINA AND SOUTH
KOREA.
TESTS SURELY ATTRACT
INTERNATIONAL ATTENTION.
THERE IS ALSO NOT THE MYSTIC
AUDIENCE.
>> TO COVER UP THE ECONOMIC
FAILURE, HE NEEDS TO SHOW OFF
OTHER --
UNIONS 11 BROKEN JACKIE CAN BE
PROUD OF.
>> TIMEWISE, HE MAY BE IN A
MOST TESTING ENVIRONMENT IT IS
MORE THAN TEN YEARS OF POWER.
THE ROADS ATTENTION IS ON
RUSSIA'S A VISION OF UKRAINE.
THE CHANCES OF RUSSIAN OR CHINA
SIDING WITH THE U.S. TO
SANCTION NORTH KOREA ANNEXED
ZERO.
>> THERE IS NO CHANCE OF ANY UN
SECURITY COUNCIL SANCTION
ACTION.
THE UN SECURITY COUNCIL COULD
NOT EVEN CONDEMN DELAYS ICBM
TESTS.
>> ALL OBSERVERS AGREE SIGNALS
TO PLENTY OF TESTING AHEAD.
IN FACT, JANUARY IS ALREADY